Колючий дріт крізь весь Курвалеті
Це селище в центральній частині Грузії – розділене
як колись були розділені села
за часів холодної війни
Тут тільки тварини можуть безперешкодно ходити туди-сюди
Вже дев’ять років минуло після грузинсько-російської війни
З того часу Євросоюз наглядає за демаркаційною лінією
Тут постійно працюють майже двісті спостерігачів
Перемир’я все ще триває, але Південна Осетія ізолювалася
з найгіршими наслідками для місцевих жителів
Селянин Давид Ваніашвілі охоче розповідає свою історію
Він провів тут майже все своє життя. Це його дім
Вісімдесят років це була територія Грузії
І що тепер? Земля стала російською?
Я живу тут вже вісімдесят років
Поки я будував дім, я був і голодний, і ситий
І куди тепер я маю піти? Я ніколи не залишу це місце
Моя мама лежить тут на кладовищі. Тут також поховані мій тато і брати
Уся моя родина
Південна Осетія відокремилась від Грузії
У серпні 2008 року Тбілісі хотів повернути провінцію військовою силою
Але тоді Росія втрутилась і перемогла грузинську армію
Слідом за цим Москва визнала Південну Осетію незалежною
Шота Утіашвілі очолював тоді ситуативний центр
при міністерстві внутрішніх справ Грузії
Йому зрозуміло, чому Росія виступила захисником сепаратистів
Ключова стратегія Росії
була в тому, щоб мати контроль над південним Кавказом
та запобігти будь-якій іноземній присутності в цьому регіоні
І таке бажання зумовлене частково тим
що це місце для них стратегічне
Але понад усе для них
контроль над постачанням енергії з Каспійського моря до всього світу
Грузія - транзитна країна для низки великих нафтопроводів
Усі вони важливі для Європи
Проте Росія будує все більше і більше
таких військових баз на території Південної Осетії
яка відповідно до міжнародного права належить Грузії
Проти російської окупації протестує ця група нескорених
Майже щодня, і в дощ і в сніг, вони стоять тут, на автобані до Тбілісі
Звідси лише одна година їзди до грузинської столиці
Демонстранти розповідають, як Росія зв’язує свої військові бази одна з одною
Два-три дні тому вони закінчили нову дорогу
Уряд Грузії щоразу б’є на сполох
коли Росія і далі розбудовується у Південній Осетії
Це блокує грузинський шлях до Європи
Тбілісі хоче стати членом ЄС і НАТО
Але на заваді стоїть невирішений конфлікт з Росією
І російські солдати щодня лише створюють нові перепони
кажуть спостерігачі з місії ЄС
Основні проблеми пов'язані з процесом
який ми називаємо "штучним розмежуванням території"
тобто створенням фізичної інфраструктури, що перешкоджає
свободі пересування місцевого населення
Тож люди не можуть по-справжньому вільно перетинати лінію
існує так званий режим кордону
Точні координати демаркаційної лінії спостерігачі ЄС
завжди мають на своїх GPS-пристроях
З міркувань безпеки
Офіційно конфлікт навколо Південної Осетії вважається "замороженим"
Для селян тут, на кризовій ділянці
це формулювання є дивним
Оскільки вони і далі страждають від примусового поділу своєї країни